You have less than 1 year left.
You ask why?
Now I will say now,
probably everyone saw that the right-wing party is leading,
and in September 25 there will be elections,
respectively,
their victory,
I think,
the probability is 75-80%.
What does that mean when they win?
The next consideration of a residence permit for permanent residence visas
will be considered by them carefully and individually with each.
I guarantee you that.
So you guys have less than 1 year.
You have time left to go to officially get a job,
receive an official salary under the contract and fully provide for yourself,
without the participation of the Job Center.